[Musik]
wir kommen bei der tanzshow über das ist
alles sehr blau ist ich glaube
meine wimpern dieses bisschen hart echt
zu viel aufmerksamkeit in der kinder
bekommen
und willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender auspackt video heute
geht es um den harry potter halloween
vans kalender aus dem film zu harry
potter dunklen künste halloween
countdown 13 tage voller überraschungen
also ich habe es im laden gesehen und
habe mir gedacht
irgendwo ist es am ende des tages auch
ein adventskalender und seien wir mal
ehrlich da steht harry potter drauf also
lasst uns mal sehen was steckt bevor wir
aber mit dem video starten können muss
ich etwas erwähnen ja ich bin nicht
verkleidet ich verkleide mich sehr gerne
und ich habe darüber nachgedacht was ich
denn machen kann eine blaue rating co
jack ist alles was mir eingefallen ist
denn ich kann wirklich kein harry potter
merge und ich kann meinen zauberstab
auch nicht finden
dafür habe ich aber harry potter
süßigkeit langweilige stinknormale
gummibärchen schnecken gummibärchen und
schokolade frosch weil dieser kalender
hier seht ja
nix und zur einstimmung wir jetzt mal so
ein schlaks preise sind schon ganz schön
habe ich nicht fünf euro kostet so eine
schokolade frei 29 gummibärchen und die
349 dass sich die beste gummi schnecke
aller zeiten ist
die konsistenz von im schlamm freuen ich
muss natürlich wissen in welche karte in
meinem schoko frost und
schnee bevor er mir weg springt nein
der ist christi von innen also den hätte
ich euch noch zeigen sollen fünf euro
artemisia lüften ja von 1798 at lisa
luft in first which to become minister
of magic
jetzt einfach mal los seid ihr bereit
ich glaube nicht
dass es wirklich einen dunklen künstler
wenn sie können es ist aber auch zum
thema halloween da sollte man schon sich
ein bisschen gruseln glaubt ihr dieses
adventskalender system wird sich jetzt
wirklich auf alles andere auch beziehen
man könnt ihr auch geburtstag
adventskalender machen halloween
adventskalender wein dienstag
adventskalender lasst uns unseren
millennium traum leben und türchen
nummer eins öffnen der türchen nummer
eins befindet sich dunkle wesen und
geister der zauberwelt
excuse me natürlich dieses videos nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle diese
ich werde nicht dafür bezahlt wir machen
keine kooperation hier das ist einfach
nur meine ehrliche meinung zu einem
produkt dunkle wesen geister der
zauberer welt was ist denn das jetzt so
ein kleines wikipedia für die hand ich
lese ich das mal vor was hier drin steht
als der basilisk harry potter in der
kammer des schreckens angreift hütet der
junge das ungetüm mit dem schwerpunkt
gräfendorf diese szene erschufen die
modellbauer einen lebensgroßen
basilisken koppigen den daniel radcliffe
harry kämpfen konnte wenn die schlange
ihr maul schloss wurden ihre zähne
eingefahren das wusste ich nicht toll
als nächstes hat man jetzt die spinne
die riesenspinne aargau keine agro man
tun
als ich das jetzt hier gelesen habe
wurde mir nicht klar das ist um fun fact
aus dem film und dunkle wesen geht aber
da hat man hier so ein kleines buch wo
man es ein paar fakten lesen kann ich
mag es ist tschechien nummer zwei sind
alles ja nur umschläge gut weil sie
den türchen nummer zwei befinden sich
haben um ein gott ist sie warum ich das
erinnert ok popstars und so geht es zum
beispiel gibt es immer so karten die man
sich dann zu hause irgendwo aufhängen
kann stellt euch mal vor anhängt ich
halt nur so dunklen künste sachen
zuhause ausgleichtreffers von
portemonnaies minecraft
nummer 3 also etwas ganz spannendes drin
moss morde tag mag ich krieg ein
bisschen emp weiß ist dass das ist ein
sticker na ja das ist ja das ist schon
cool aus aber irgendwie ein bisschen aus
wie sohn ben die sticker auf türchen
nummer 4 befindet sich in bella tricks
eines trainers ist so eine kleine
beschreibung wäre glaube ich ganz gut
dass man sagen könnte ja das ist ein
sticker dass man einfach nur karten hier
haben wir die tore
das darf man auch nur so sagen tut so
als
wenn sie jetzt kommt die millennials mit
ihrem harry potter lasst uns bitte harry
potter das ist das einzige was uns
unserem leben eine freude bringen und
das ist eine welt in der wir gerne
selber leben würden denn diese welt wird
immer ungemütlicher und immer schlimmer
10 verschwinden wir gerne in der welt
professor lupin süßer dementoren
abwertung chris rezept ist von harris
begegnung mit den lehrern die menschen
inspiriert so und helfen sie das rezept
hier sind sie zu taten von das ist in
kakao den muss ich unbedingt mal
nachmachen denn wenn man von einem
dementoren
angegriffen wird wie oft greift ein
mentor ein an und man schafft sie was
ich gerade meine in einem endlich
angreift dann schafft er sie eigentlich
immer was sollte dagegen machen außer
hier pathos wie kommt es dass leute
wissen was sie nach einem dementoren
angriff machen sollen um quasi die
stimmung wieder hoch zu kriegen
schokolade essen wie viele leute haben
es denn geschafft ihre seele ausgesaugt
zu kriegen und es dann doch überlebt und
so in das ist dass kakao und hier haben
wir zwei untersetzer aber diese
untersetzer sind natürlich jetzt keine
richtigen untersetzer sondern
papageno aber der 20 euro gekostet man
muss auch seine 20 euro kalender das ist
jetzt nicht 70 euro
ist das etwa ein kleines spiel das ist
natürlich immer fünf drin und es ist
leuchte mit einer taschenlampe oder dem
handy durch das sichtfenster richtet den
lichtstrahl auf eine wand in einem
schwach beleuchteten zimmer erschrecke
deine freunde
[Gelächter]
dann ein kasten drumherum
nummer sechs ich wollte schon sagen
nikolaus aber nein wenn man den 13 tage
vor halloween öffnen sollen dann muss
man ihn am 19 oktober bis november man
muss ihn am 19 oktober anfangen zu
öffnen dann hat man am 31 13 also nicht
cool aus in tschechien nummer sechs ein
memory-spiel zu einer guten partie sagt
ich nicht nein wie viele jahre das herz
das ich mir krieg gespielt hat dann
folge mord voldemort uns ist das die oma
doch das ist die oma die sie doch da auf
diesem friedhof mitnehmen die wohnungen
dann verwandelt sie sich
da kommt auf jeden fall nadine i und
dann schauen sie schnell wieder ab nicht
geschafft aber jetzt ist der nächste
dran dass bin auch wieder ich
und
nächste runde beatrix
ich weiß wer in der nächsten runde
ja das ist mehr mobil
wir haben den komischen geschmack mit
dem magix tweets anders schmecken gibt
sind ja noch mal andere
das sind die exakt gleichen warum kosten
dienen 329 thalia was ist da los die
kosten 349 die kosten 3 29 jetzt könnte
man denken aber place in dem ein mehr
drin oder wenn jemanden nein hier ist
der kilopreis 58 euro und hier ist der
kilopreis 83 euro türchen nummer sieben
ist groß und drinsteckt
das finde ich jetzt echt cooler button
nur ich persönlich lasse in schablonen
für ein quiz und so sehen die motive aus
das ist geil nicht lange oder das
heiligtümer des todes zeichen darf
endlich ist noch mal eine anleitung wie
man das mache ich sehr cool weil ich
meine was macht man zu halloween kürbis
schnitzen und meisten leute sind jetzt
nicht so talentiert darin ich glaube ja
man kann das dann so draufkleben
assistance sticker und dann kostet diese
sticker so aus schnippeln
ein paar die spielen da bin ich doch
dabei in den bussen ratespiel heißes
zauber gegen zauberer hilde zwei teams
mit jeweils mindestens zwei spielern
jedes team erhält eine karte mit einem
bleistift ein blatt papier bestimmt
einen spieler der zeichnet während die
andere das motive rathenow setzte ein
zeitlimit zeichnet das ist wie activity
nur mit dem zeichnen denken dass das
jetzt auch nicht sehen die einen sind
ihm voldemort und die anderen sind team
harry potter dann gibt es da so worte
die man zeichnen muss auch helfen den
harry potter themenabend ist das
bestimmt eine tolle sache
wir haben wieder ein buch sind die
märchen von beedle dem barden klar kennt
man kleines detail wurde anja liegt
jemandem aufgefallen dass das märchen
von den drei brüdern okay also man liest
nicht die geschichte ich kenne mich
kenne mich mit wieder den wahren so was
gar nicht aus und ich dachte so jetzt
liest man das märchen von den drei
brüdern dass man aus dem film auch
kennen dann ist hier was in ruhen
schrift geschrieben das kann ich leider
nicht lesen und dann geht es hier auch
schon mit der nächsten geschichte weiter
also man liest leider keine ganze
geschichte und eine biopsie irgendwelche
höherem berufen und dann gibt es das
nächste märchens in welchem netz zum
anschlag wichtig bin ich die nummer 10
ist wirklich ende sehr kleines paket
auch hier werden wir person
das kann ich mir irgendwo fest machen
ist das originale ja schon das kann ich
mir an meine jacke fest machen das ist
also drauf ich habe gerade voll verdeckt
dass wir ja nur 13 tüchern haben und das
wird schon zum ende kommen tisch immer
elf auch sehr klein ein
schlüsselanhänger die nur auf dem
schlauch was das also es ist
klar ohne witz ich weiß nicht wie viele
von diesem motiv also pins mit diesem
motiv ich mittlerweile habe ich glaube
es sind sehr viele viele mehr als ihr
liebstes bucht man auch pins [ __ ] an
seine federmäppchen und jetzt kommen wir
auch schon zum letzten türchen nummer 13
es ist keine erklärung zu machen ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher das ist das ist fürs
handy zum dran kleben also auf eine
hülle und dann kannst du hier eine
kreditkarte oder busfahrkarte oder
irgendwas reinstecken ich finde das
design mega cool ich würde es jetzt
nicht auf meine scheiße hier aufkleben
weil das wäre verschwendung aber ich
glaube ich das machen
jetzt drohnen fazit also 19 eur 99 20
euro was bekommt man geht mir das ganze
doch mal durch also ich finde der
kalender an sich ist mehr gut gestaltet
ich finde die idee so halloween im
kalender zu haben auch voll cool weil
ich als kind halloween auch schon
geliebt habe also ich konnte es kaum
abwarten dass dieser tag kommen dass man
von tür zu tür geht sie verkleidet und
süßigkeiten sammelt das war für mich
wirklich immer ein absolutes highlight
deswegen wenn ich jetzt ein kind hätte
was voll auf harry potter steht würde
ich glaube ich nicht nachdenken und mein
kind dieses buch kaufen das findet die
usa dem wird natürlich ganz fantastisch
weil sie sich schon wieder was
ausgedacht haben womit man geld aus den
taschen ziehen kann aber ich hätte mich
gefreut wenn ich als kind so was gehabt
für ein highlight ist wirklich das
kürbis ausstands ding die handy hülle
für nicht cool die die fun facts zu den
film finde ich auch gut aber ich wüsste
jetzt wenn ich jünger wäre endlich
wahrscheinlich alles mega da hätte ich
wahrscheinlich mich über jedes türchen
übels gefreut und gerade weil sowas hat
ein konzept von lou bega also ich glaube
für die kinder oder die jungen ganz
junger teenager ist das mega 100 prozent
ich bin ja jetzt halt nicht so ganz
abgeholt aber das okay der preis ist in
ordnung denke ich würde sagen stiftung
warentest sagt okay aber teuer
irgendwie gefallen bis zum nächsten mal
meine kleinen zauberer und ex anwalt bis
hierhin durchgehalten habe ich an im
letzten video den six adventskalender
von germany's next topmodel ausgepackt
und die ohrringe kann nicht tragen und
das ist wirklich komisch weil ich krieg
malerische reaktion von o ring aber die
gehen